tu pensais passer une journée tranquille
mais soudain les sirènes retentissent la
télévision s'arrête flash spécial s'est
confirmée et missiles nucléaires se
dirige sur paris et toutes les grandes
villes de france tu n'as que quelques
minutes pour te préparer et tu vas faire
beaucoup d'erreurs ça on le sait car le
13 janvier 2018 à hawaii par erreur une
alerte nucléaire a été déclenché et les
gens ont fait n'importe quoi on vous
explique donc tout ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire pour survivre à une attaque
nucléaire
15 minutes c'est ce qu'il faut pour
qu'un missile tiré depuis la russie à
athènes la france le temps que soient
détectés confirmé que l' alerte arrive
sur ton téléphone il ne te reste plus
que quelques minutes avant l'impact
quelle sera la puissance de cette bombe
elle ne faisait que 15 petits kilos
tonnes de tnt soit 12 km de dévastation
absolue et seulement 100 mille japonais
morts dites-vous que 70% de la
population a survécu à l'explosion
initiale ça ne devrait toucher que le
centre de paris bonne nouvelle non
malheureusement les bons modernes sont
bien plus dévastatrice prenons les rs 24
car c'est les topol m la très grande
majorité de l'arsenal nucléaire russe et
ils ont été mis en mouvement récemment
je dis ça je dis rien ils contiennent
des ogives oscille entre 200 et 500
kilos tonnes de tnt 10 à 30 fois
hiroshima au point d'impact une boule de
feu de 3500 degré qui va vaporiser toute
vie et tout bâtiment sur un kilomètre
dans cette zone tu n'as absolument
aucune chance de survie le flash est
longue de choc vont totalement détruire
paris intra muros jusqu'à saint denis si
tu n'es pas protégés et chances de
survie sont minces les effets de
l'explosion vont s'étendre jusqu'à
versailles où les dégâts seront plus
légers mais on peut faire bien pire avec
la tsar bomba indices pas 30 mai presque
4000 fois la puissance d'hiroshima la
plus puissante explosion nucléaire
jamais enregistrée et encore on l'avait
[ __ ] à la moitié de sa puissance max ça
ne l'a pas empêché de raser un village à
55 kilomètres de là soufflant des
fenêtres jusqu'en finlande et en suède à
900 kilomètres à la ronde l'île de
france serait rasée il y aurait des
brûlés au troisième degré jusqu à
fontainebleau vous avez peut-être
récemment entendu parler du missile
s'attend d'eux tout le monde a flippé à
cause du nom nous mais on devrait plutôt
fip et de sa puissance il est conçu pour
transporter 15 têtes nucléaires à la
fois 15 cibles qui subiront
simultanément 750 kilos tonnes chacune
de coarraze et toutes les principales
villes de france le meilleur moyen d'y
échapper l'art est d'habiter dans la
creuse heureusement s'attend d'eux n'est
toujours pas opérationnel tu l'auras
compris quoi qu'il arrive tout va être
détruit tu dois trouver un abri solide
évite absolument d'être près d'une
fenêtre
la moitié des victimes de l'explosion
nous serons à cause du verre brisé des
débris volants ou des bâtiments qui
s'effondre évite aussi de te mettre dans
un frigo comme indiana jones les
scientifiques ont calculé dans la
réalité non seulement elle n'aurait pas
pu survivre aux radiations d'aussi près
mais il serait mort à l'impact au sol ou
dans le métro ou une cave c'est parfait
on te réfugier sous une table qui pourra
tank et le potentiel écroulement du
plafond c'est ce que berthe la tortueux
apprenez à des milliers d'écoliers
américains pendant la guerre froide duck
and cover haut et un dernier conseil
bush l'évier et ouvre tous les robinets
tu as une baignoire remplie là aussi ce
pas pour ti plonger un juste que
l'explosion va te couper toutes les
canalisations et tu seras sûrement sans
eau ouais pense déjà à l'après
car la bombe est arrivé
ça y est elle tombe elle ne va pas
exploser au sol mais à onze kilomètres
d'altitude pour maximiser long de choc
le premier danger sera cette lumière
loin d'être innocente c'est le flash
thermique 35 % de l'énergie de la bombe
libéré sous forme de lumière pur et
concentré qui ferai de toi l'équivalent
d'une fourmi sous une loupe en plein
soleil en une milieu secondes tu prends
un coup de soleil équivalent à 540 jours
sur une plage caniculaire sans avoir mis
de crème solaire ça ira jusqu'à
brouiller des nerfs en profondeur au
moins ça fera un peu moins mal pour te
protéger du flash est pas compliqué il
faut être à l'ombre c'est ce que nous
ont prouvé les sinistres sombre
d'hiroshima des malheureux carbonisé qui
ont fait ombrage au bois derrière eux
qui n'a pas brûlé tu peux aussi porter
des vêtements blancs qui protégeront ton
corps en réfléchissant la lumière
mortels on a aussi pu l'observer sur les
victimes d'hiroshima leur peau été
brûlés mais pas là où leurs kimonos
clair les avaient protégés une mère a
même été miraculé juste parce qu'elle
étendait son linge blanc a contrario un
vêtement sombre va absorber le
rayonnement et aggravé les brûlures même
si tu es loin ne regarde jamais dans la
direction de la lumière ça te brûler la
rétine dis toi que même comme ça même en
fermant les yeux c'est tellement
lumineux que tu risques de ne plus rien
voir pendant quelques minutes
trouvera la vue le flash de la tsar
bomba était visible jusqu'à 1000
kilomètres de distance à temps le
cauchemar n'est pas fini quelques
secondes après le flash vient l'ombre de
choc une rafale supersonique qui
s'abattra sur toi avec la force d'un mur
en béton tu as même pas dix secondes
pour te protéger si c'est pas encore
fait dans sa cave ça devrait aller mais
juste tes mains sur tes oreilles et
ouvre la bouche si tu ne veux pas tu est
impensable pulvérisé
ça y est c'est fini tu es en vie si tu
sors ton portable pour appeler tes
proches tu vas remarquer qu'il est
complètement bousillé en effet une bombe
nucléaire en haute altitude provoque une
violente impulsions électromagnétiques
qui va griller la plupart des systèmes
électroniques ton pc gaming foutu une
solution à sa décla sirène retentit
emballe ton téléphone dans du papier
d'alu ça fera office de cage de faraday
rudimentaire un genre de boucliers anti
ondes ton téléphone sera précieux pour
contacter les secours si le réseau a
tenu bon quinon utilise une radio à
piles pour te tenir au courant quand tu
vas sortir la tête dehors ça va être une
vision d'horreur la ville résonnera des
cris de milliers de blessés brûlé vif à
moitié aveugle et sourd qui vont mourir
dans les décombres ou loin tu verras
monter un sinistre nuage en forme de
champignon la chaleur de l'impact va
aspirer tout l'air alentours ravivant
les incendies quel beau spectacle
mais le temps presse dans environ un
quart d'heure descendre hautement
radioactifs vont retomber c'est la
tristement célèbre plus noirs de
nagasaki la pire chose à faire serait de
prendre sa voiture pour fuir au loin
simplement parce que tout le monde aura
la même idée et tu vas te retrouver
coincés dans les bouchons sous la pluie
noire chaque respiration va bientôt
devenir un poison trouve toi vite un
abri en hauteur loin du sol si possible
mais pas trop non plus pour éviter
d'être exposées aux vents et aux dépôts
radioactifs sur les toits va chercher un
masque pour le coup vide ou un tissus
mouillés et ne respire qu'avec ça
profites en pour colmater les portes et
les fenêtres avec du linge humide afin
d'éviter les courants d'air qui charrie
ray les poussières radioactives
tu te rappelles qu'après avoir survécu à
l'explosion dans son frigo indiana jones
et karchériser par les militaires à
cette partie là est vrai débarrasse toi
des vêtements que tu portais et reims
toi intégralement au savon et à l'eau
n'oublie rien oreilles nez bouche mais
ne frotte pas trop fort pour ne pas
créer des micro blessure tu ne voudrais
pas qu'une poussière reste coincé sous
ta peau l'idéal aussi serait de faire la
boule à zéro trop risqué de garder des
cheveux et de la barbe potentiellement
plein de radionucléides avec un peu de
chance tu habites à moins de 20 km d'une
centrale nucléaire et tu as chez toi des
comprimés diode
est ce qu'on donne aux habitants en cas
d'accident tu laval et ça sature la
thyroïde d'iodé stable c'est génial
parce que comme ça la radioactivité n'a
plus de place pour se fixer et ça
t'évitera des cancers des années plus
tard et vite tu as max 24 heures pour
prendre la pilule malgré toutes ces
précautions lionne n'est pas le seul
élément radioactif césium strontium de
l'effet surtout pas entrer dans son
corps par la nourriture contaminée
notamment
vingt-quatre heures après l'explosion la
plupart des poussières sont devenus
moitié moins radioactives les isotopes
produits ont en effet une demi vie très
courte au bout de 48 heures la baisse
est de 80% et après deux semaines tout
est revenu à la normale pour l'heure il
faut donc rester chez toi si tu venais à
manquer d'eau n'oublie pas la chasse
d'eau des toilettes ou ton chauffe eau
en ouvrant les robinets à laitages pour
créer un appel d'air puis en ouvrant
ceux d'en bas tu peut encore récupérer
quelques précieux litres coincé dans les
tuyaux bonne nouvelle un essai nucléaire
aura confirmé qu'une canette de bière
est radié sera de nouveau buvable une
douzaine d'heures après l'impact si tu
es enceinte pas de panique contrairement
à une idée reçue on n'a pas observé de
malformations de troubles génétiques
significatif chez les bébés post
hiroshima pour l'heure il faut s'occuper
de toi si tu as des blessures notamment
sur les parties de ta peau exposées à
des radiations tu verra apparaître des
brûlures dont il faudra prendre soin
situer correctement race et bravo tu
dois limiter les dégâts surtout ne
touche pas aux clock tu risquerais une
infection
les survivants commencent à émerger de
leurs abris militaires en combinaison
sont en train de les évacuer alliés ou
ennemis quelle importance de toute façon
une guerre nucléaire ne peut pas être
gagnée ce qu'elle finit irrémédiablement
par la destruction quasi totale des deux
camps ne croyez pas qu'une bombe
atomique ce l'arc seulement depuis un
avion une par une comment 45 parle
aujourd'hui de missiles tirés de
n'importe où sur le globe que ce soit
une base un camion un jet ou un sous
marin qui peuvent atteindre l'espace
avant de retomber sur leurs cibles on a
bien des radars anti missiles et des
intercepteurs pour se défendre mais
voilà le problème les nouvelles
générations vont vite trop vite en
empruntant des trajectoire en zigzag les
rendant impossible anticipées ensuite on
va généralement pas lancer une bombe
mais plusieurs avec des leurs pour noyer
les radars ennemis enfin coup de grâce
les missiles en portent eux-mêmes
plusieurs têtes nucléaires capables de
se disperser pour frapper plusieurs
cibles c'est le cas de satan 2 dont on
vous parlait précédemment de quoi
couvrir un territoire grand comme toute
la france autant vous dire que la seule
défense c'est notre capacité d' attaque
la dissuasion nucléaire si tu commences
goethe atomise en 2017 le département de
sécurité globale de l'université de
princeton a publié le scénario tactique
le plus probable si la russie décidé de
lancer sur tout petit bond sur un pays
de l'otan inutile de vous dire que ça
dégénère rapidement moins de 15 minutes
après le départ du premier missile
l'otan va répliquer avec une force digne
de l'apocalypse
regardez la densité de missiles personne
ne survivra à ça une bombe qui tomberait
sur paris signifierait une guerre
nucléaire totale
les scientifiques débattent encore pour
savoir s'il suivra ou non un hiver
nucléaire est une famine nucléaire mais
une chose est sûre je ne sais pas
comment sera la troisième guerre
mondiale et je sais que la quatrième se
fera à coup de pierres de bâtons